speaking of German stuff I want to quick
shout out to these guys hold on hold on
Dave they've done some stuff with yes
with yes theory
yeah the Zack and Jay show these two
English youtubers they are I should say
they're from the UK they're not both
English but they went to burg hein that
Club is it in Germany it's in Germany
right oh is this way you're talking
about it yeah yeah cuz they they got in
and they decided not to divulge what is
in Berlin yeah so it's in Germany um
this is the one we would have went to I
mean I don't think we could have gotten
into this because basically they they
say that it's runt they it's run by this
guy I don't know his name but basically
some people wait you know three four
hours in line and just just get turned
down okay and so they they kind of go
around the town and and they're dressed
you know what I think what we would
consider normal mm-hm and they ask
people like Oh could we get in like this
and then a lot of people were like no so
they talked to a few people and they say
everyone we know that got in was wearing
a [ __ ] fishnet so maybe we just have
to wear a fishnet
oh yeah cuz it's like a gay club I don't
know that is necessarily gay I just
think it's like it is that's how it
started but then it's still kind of a
gay club like it it has like everyone
goes there uh-huh
but it still has that history and it's
like part of the allure okay all right
well either way I think it uh well they
so they find someone who's been - they
find a few people have been a bird high
in like a bunch of times and they're
kind of giving them you know sort of
sort of tips and and it generally just
seems like there's really no way to
prepare like you it's it's a hundred
percent of 50-50 you're either gonna get
in or you're not
there's no way to trick it and so they
meet up with this girl who remains
anonymous because she doesn't want to
risk never getting in again which is
kind of wild and so she helps them with
their outfits and stuff and they end up
getting that fun it's that fun
I mean they they said it's [ __ ] crazy
the only thing that they give away and I
don't want to spoil it here you should
you should go watch this video if you're
listening to this they they describe the
room they walk into and it sounded like
a [ __ ] haunted house I was pretty
intrigued and then there's this talk of
the pissed chamber which is just like
this shower and I guess you can go in
there and get peed on or people just pee
on each other in there which is [ __ ]
crazy
I feel like that's not even the weirdest
[ __ ] that goes on there no like there's
group sex rooms there's like dominatrix
rooms where you can walk in and there's
someone dominating another person like
yeah it's crazy this [ __ ] I've heard
from there the stories I've heard it's
nuts so yeah it's like the box but not a
show yeah like you're in it's people are
really just doing that and you can just
walk up and just do it it's like I
really got a piss the bathroom line is
really long do you mind if I'm just hop
in the shower
I'm gonna just pee on this guy [ __ ]
I'm gonna pee on this guy that's the
dessert room cuz yeah oh there's our
stalls here really gross that's rather
than this time you'll you can ever say
that sentence and not get in trouble
[ __ ] I'm a pee on this guy and it's
consensual between both party so bro
when you say is it that fun it sounds
like it is it sounds like it is I mean a
group sex room you know how many weirdos
are probably just in in there just like
oh you can watch you can you can
participate if you want to it really is
just a playground for your weirdest sins
your weirdest vices we're never getting
in just because you questioned it and
they probably have a file on everyone
when you get there so I'm not
questioning anything
I if anything i'm encouraging this yeah
the almighty behind it sounds like I was
listening to one of the podcasts I was
Andrew Santino and Bobby Lee and he was
talking about he went to a party at
Miley Cyrus's house nice and he said
it's the only house it's only party he's
been doing Hollywood that actually lived
up to like people's thoughts of what a
Hollywood party would be okay and he
said she had you know she spent
thousands and thousands of dollars on
this on this party at her house it was a
birthday party or some [ __ ] and it was
all like they had like different areas
in the backyard [ __ ] his giant [ __ ]
yard and they had it all set up and
themed and there was like different
areas where you would go to do drugs or
you would go to like mud wrestler you go
to like this area to do something else
he said it was [ __ ] wild that's how I
imagined some like Bergheim being it's
just different like you just go off soon
you find out new courtyard and there's
people just doing ketamine and you're
like oh this is a ketamine space I feel
like you'd be like an asylum in there
like long hallways with like flickering
lights crazy music like echoing through
that whole [ __ ] and you just like open
up a doors just like sorry the whole
thing is that like remember that hallway
and then haunted house we went down that
with the inflatable [ __ ] on the side
yeah yeah that's the whole thing
ya know bros like a scooby-doo it's like
an episode of Scooby Doo like it's just
going out of doors and like little
monsters and [ __ ] chasing them and every
time you leave a room your outfits
different and you go in one door and
come out the other side the other side
home what and then you go go nice all
over your jeans yeah than a gag ball in
your mouth
[Laughter]
I'm just thinking about I from [ __ ]
UTA in Germany who came to our show and
then we were like talking about this and
you're like is there like some crazy
Club here and he's like oh yeah big hein
but kind it's crazy man talk about being
in there for [ __ ] 25 hours it opens
on Thursday and closes on Monday and
doesn't about closes between I think
it's Monday morning okay yeah so it
doesn't close so and they sell
toothbrushes there and [ __ ] so people
can just people just stay if they're on
like a drug bender you can just stay and
there's areas you can sleep two row
apparently this is all hearsay for me
but bro lining up on Saturday morning
it's so crazy
yeah going to a club it like 7:00 a.m.
in fishnets yeah right after coffee just
yeah I'm just gonna get it started [ __ ]
I'm yeah heading to Buckeye I'm going to
Bergen that dude what was that [ __ ]
Daybreakers that they were doing out
here uh yeah that rings a bell what is
that it's like you like it was like a
they basically had like a club at like
6:00 in the morning 5:00 6:00 in the
morning and it was for office people to
party in the morning and then go to work
dude it was I only know about it because
my boy Eric he was helping his girl and
at the time she was like working with a
friend who was starting like a beverage
company so they were sponsoring one of
the day breaker events and so he had to
go there and he was just helping him
like Pat I hand out drinks and or
whatever and he said dude it was [ __ ]
wild like people just he said either
these people were rolling in after
having partied from like somewhere else
in LA or they were just straight-up like
you know because I guess by the way I
think they did it didn't like a Friday
morning I think but yeah although
Daybreakers
Daybreakers la la live get ready to wake
up and dance gee breaker dance party
yeah yeah it's a sober rave but because
sober rave yeah Eric was saying no way
brother way too sweaty silent disco for
yuppies were you head into the Facebook
offices stop by day breaker for a
pancake and a rave Eric loses the
podcast the Eric if I [ __ ] up one of
these details you gotta let me know the
but it was whatever what's up Eric by
the way yeah either way he was there and
and what I'm saying is we gotta go to
day breaker now definitely do it as soon
as it's legal and safe like God will go
can you imagine this I think dude I
think I think kid went to one of those
too it sounds really corporate website
yeah we got to do we got to go to one
before we record the podcast like comes
fresh from day breaker I mean that'd be
good be good neon like on our faces
what's up guys we just had a crazy
morning
pupils biggest [ __ ] it was definitely
sober very sober no but we're actually
sober you're just the energy of the rave
that you know that makes us feel like
we're rolling I I don't know why I love
the thought of like all these corporate
25 to 30 year olds actually staying
sober and going to this rave before work
yeah feels like so it feels like
something you do on a corporate retreat
yeah
you